c'est clarinette faut se méfier d'une
once d'or rendre la pareille j'ai
toujours cru que c'était rendre la
pareille en
biochimie à 14 heures bonjour brut je
m'appelle fleurs j'ai 29 ans et je suis
prof de français en collège depuis cinq
ans alors j'ai depuis un an un petit
carnet dans lequel je note toutes les
perles de mes élèves ils appellent ça le
carnet de la honte soumettiez l'année
sympathique le roi a régné il m'a induit
d'erreur consumer le mariage il est mort
parce qu'il avait les haltères boucher
faut pas chercher midi à quatorze heures
moi j'ai dit en classe ce qu'il fallait
faire preuve de clémence donc on m'a
demandé qui était clément ce
qu'ils me disent et medic et clémence ça
arrive souvent il faut pas chercher midi
à quatorze heures ça signifie qu'il faut
pas faire compliqué quand on peut faire
simple je pense que les élèves entendre
d expression et comme c'est il essaye de
les répéter mais sans vraiment
comprendre le sens de l'expression il
met dessus des mots qu'ils emploient
plus j'espère que la roue tourne fort
vu tourner le pain d'épicés quand
j'étais si jeune plus jamais compris le
sens tanguy sous la roche désolé j'ai
pas du coca light meilleure personne ce
soir sur un site house et moi passer du
coq à l'âne ça veut dire passer d'un
sujet à un autre sans vraiment de
transition parce que font beaucoup les
élèves toute expression a son
explication tout dire je regardais
l'oeil l'oeil au beurre noir ce que j'ai
souvent des élèves qui me disent aussi
l'oeil au beurre noir je lisais que
cette expression que venait en fait de
la couleur du beurre qui se teinte et
lorsque on le faisait chauffer cela du
16e siècle parfois il faut aller un peu
chercher parce que ça coule pas de
source le sens des expressions soit on
connaît pas l'expression on essaye de se
l'approprier de la répéter il ya un an
via un souci et je pense qu'on l'a tous
fait un même en étant prof de français
il ya des expressions que j'ai
découverte vraiment tard comme être en
âge ma grand mère elle me disait souvent
chaud chez en a je suis en âge je
pensais que alizés qu'elle était vieille
donc voilà donc on essaye de répéter des
choses qu'on a entendues
et puis après on fait pas forcément
attention au sens des expressions je
pense que ça crée pas mal d'erreurs chez
les élèves j'ai énormément comme même au
lieu de quand même est ce que tout le
monde se trompe ya des adultes qui se
trompe très souvent on aggrave le mal
par la swan yade moi même je pense que
parfois je me trompe sur certaines
expressions n'a pas il y en a qu'on
utilise beaucoup plus que d'autres et
qu'on il ya des expressions aussi
j'imagine selon les régions qui sont
plus exploitées et parfois on n'a jamais
entendu telle ou telle expression et on
se dit mais qu'est ce que c'est qu'est
ce que ça signifie d'où ça vient donc il
ya aussi beaucoup d'adultes qui se
trompe sur sur les expressions ça c'est
sûr y'a sa chanteuse ou hdl latinisation
situe hors de ma vue elle explique que
c'est comme ça qu'elle laissait quelque
chose qu'elle disait alors ça je n'ai
pas eu parce qu'en fait ça a fait un tel
bruit sur les réseaux que les élèves ont
tout de suite su que ça ne se disaient
pas donc ils n'ont pas ressorti en
classe si ce n'est dans la chanson
l'évolution des mots et des expressions
sadate clairement pas d'hier et que on a
des expressions qui nous viennent du 15e
du xvième siècle et qui sont encore là
aujourd'hui donc qu'on a du mal à
expliquer parce que le contexte n'y ait
plus je pense à la pendaison de
crémaillère c'est quelque chose qui
littéralement ne se fait plus du tout
mais on a gardé l'expression pour
célébrer le premier repas d'un nouveau
logement donc c'est les mots restent
mais les l'effet partent parfois et
c'est beau aussi je trouve